right-hander logan gilbert on the mount
tonight for the m's five and five this
season with a 5-1 era he is winless in
his last seven starts so one away for
the red sox and that will bring out
first baseman kyle schwarber
shorter the former chicago cub
hitting 261 with 29 home runs and 61
runs batted in the one-two on the way in
a swing and a miss by schwarber for
strike three and there's strikeout
number one for logan gilbert
two up and two down for the red sox here
in the top of the first inning here's
shortstop xander bogarts just off the
cover 19 il
on friday
so he missed 10 days
gilbert
looking in has the sign
now the wind-up and the 3-2 pitch on the
way to bogart swing and a miss for
strike three got him back-to-back
strikeouts for logan gilbert here in the
top of the first and he takes here at
boston one two three eduardo rodriguez
gets the call in the opener 11-8 this
season he's got a 5-1-5 era hit hard
last time out so the mariners have
runners on at first and third nobody out
and here's first baseman ty france
die batting 287 16 home runs and 61 runs
batted in hitting 3 22 since the break
on the ground one quick skip schwarber
fires down to bogarts on to first base
for the double play as crawford scores
and the mariners get a run in the first
inning one nothing
endeavors having a great year for boston
hitting 273 33 home runs
102 runs banded in here in the middle of
september
ripping right through upper level heat
three straight strikeouts from logan
gilbert renfro hitting 263 the one-two
pitch swing and a miss and a breaking
ball for strike three logan gilbert
strikes out hunter renfrow already four
strikeouts after just two innings of
work holy smokes logan gilbert so two on
and nobody out and that'll bring up
catcher tom murphy
pitch number seven to murphy
line drives snared on a hop
onto second base good play by bogarts
but a run scores that is toro the lead
off walk comes all the way around
and it's now two nothing mariners here
is
jared kellnick
and he takes strike three
oh he threw him a
slider down and away celtic didn't think
so he thought it was ball four i thought
it was good call and a good pitch
all right two man down and here's dylan
moore the left fielder
he's hitting 176 but he does have 12
homers
good fastball puts him away eddie
walking slowly back to the dugout
glacius recently acquired by the red sox
reacquired by the red sox played here
previously of course
he hits this one high and hard to left
field back by the wall at the 376 sign
leaping and it's gone
jose iglesias clears the wall just over
the 376 time first hit of the night for
the red sox produces their first run of
the night iglesias gets the home run and
it's a 2-1 seattle league
schwarber is the prototypical strong man
power hitter big guy and when you see
him you know he's not laying any bumps
down got off to a tremendous start with
washington earlier this year the o2 pits
swing and a miss fastball went right
after him got him right there and
that'll do it with the socks they get a
home run from iglesias we go bottom
three jp crawford up against eduardo
rodriguez
yes made a good pitch again 20
or 92 miles an hour to strike him out
and down goes crawford that brings up
the cleanup hitter kyle sager sager
grounded out to xander bogarts to end
the first inning hitting 209 on the
season but does have 34 home runs
94 runs batted in
rodriguez 2-2 pitch swing and a miss
awful swing by sager he strikes out gets
tagged by vasquez
so seattle has a base runner but doesn't
score we've played three full at
t-mobile park here's third baseman
rafael devers denver's over one logan
struck him out in the second
gilbert five strikeouts here's the
wind-up and the 2-2 to denver swing and
a miss and make it six two outs nobody
on top of the fourth for jd martinez
here's the wind-up and again the 3-2 to
martinez swing and a miss for strike
three there is strikeout number seven
and counting for logan gilbert he fans
jd martinez and that's it for boston in
the top of the fourth inning
toro walked
ended up scoring the mariner's second
run in the second inning vasquez calling
for fastball
gets a called third strike at the top of
the zone may have missed at 92 but got
the call from quinn walcott
and uh torrance who singled in the
second one for one
swing and a miss
struck him out
that is three straight strikeouts
for eduardo rodriguez 2-1 mariners and
here is right fielder hunter renfro
he got him off the bat into the glove
eighth strikeout from logan gilbert and
now iglesias comes up with a tying run
90 feet away jose holmard just over the
glove of the leaping left fielder dylan
moore into left center field his first
time up
and a little pop-up in the right
charging in hanniger sliding and it
drops in the run will score and the red
sox have tied it up
iglesias drops in a base hit it's a 2-2
game his second knock
now the red sox have runners on at first
and third with two outs
a 2-2 tie and the banner will be first
baseman kyle schwarber as logan gilbert
tries to navigate some
choppy waters here in the top half of
the fifth the gilbert 2-1 pitch swaying
and a pop-up in the shallow left field
dylan moore coming in moore is there to
make the catch that's gonna retire the
side the red sox get one and that's it
they tie it up we go to the bottom of
the fifth halfway point our score
it's the mariners two and the red sox
two
so here's france grounded into a double
play three six three with a run scoring
in the first
and then hit a fly ball to left field
and the pitch swing at a high fly left
field he got under it
verdugo is there toward the line he goes
he makes the catch and shout out left to
retire the side and bring up alex
verdugo
he's one for two a fly to center left
center field a nice running catch made
by kelnick then a base hitting a run
scored in the fifth base hit to right
trying to put him away here left-hand
hitter verdugo the 2-2 from gilbert
swang and i miss struck him out on the
slider
logan gilbert a boy's
rookie really pitching out of trouble
nine strikeouts matches his career best
now pitch hitter jake bowers grabs a bat
he hits for dylan moore the nine hole
with two outs
hard hit ground ball fair bobbled by
schwarber
and with that bowers is
aboard mariners have two one with two
out for mitch haniger now
high fly ball
out to left field verdugo at the long
gone
[Applause]
his 33rd home run on the year
takes his rbi total to 82.
xander bogart's one for three with a
double
swinging a fly ball that one hammer to
center field racing back kellnick it is
gone home run
zander strikes over the wall here in
seattle
to cut it to a two-run advantage and the
red sox are within two and here's devers
who's had a tough night two strikeouts
and a pop to short
hill swing hit a drive that one headed
for right that's deep and that ball is
gone back to back home runs for the red
sox
rafael devers with number 34. and the
red sox are very much alive here in
seattle
back to back go bogarts and devers here
in the eighth inning with two down and
nobody on
bars was up as a pinch hitter and he hit
the shot
off schwarber for the error that opened
the gates to three runs jake bowers
hitting 220.
taylor fires
slider hitting the air to center field
playable
[ __ ] moving back in front of the track
makes the catch oh their threat goes by
the boards we go to the ninth inning
seattle five boston four it's up to
christian vasquez for the red sox
five four two ounce nobody on top of the
night
is 1-2
routine fly ball
kellnick over
and the mariners take game one
5-4 the final score
you